this fish is a fruit bat that lives
in the atlantic ocean
if it is not protected it could
disappear like around twenty other
deep sea species it is to
avoid this that the european
deputies voted a new regulation which limits
the  deep-sea fishing in
the northeast atlantic specific fishing areas
have been defined here for
blue ling there for black scabbardfish
these strips along the coast
correspond to the footprints
left by vessels between 2009 and 2011
there  where they have already practiced
deep-sea fishing
we can assume content from the fact that we have
fished in this area that precisely
there is no rock or
Arab ecosystem these are the cats moore was
offense shin ichi repaired by  the rock or
or by the corals a compromise which
makes it possible to safeguard the
economic activity while protecting the
seabed fishing limited in extent but
also in depth since it will be
prohibited to fish below 800
m  other measure a strengthening of
controls and sanctions
20% of vessels will welcome
observers for scientific monitoring
we have put in place a scientific
scientific control system if you want
much more important than in any
other fishing regulation we will have a
rendering of scientific data as  we
have no data on any
fisheries that will ultimately allow us
to adjust measures and better
protect fish and the seabed
[Music]